Now, if we peak inside the black box however, we find that it is not just
Bala who is using the resources in the virtual platform, but there
is also Piero and there is also Kim, and possibly others who are also
running their own applications. Their own operating
system on the same shared hardware resources.
Why would we want to do this? Well, unless we are quite unlucky, the hope
is that sharing hardware resources across several different
user communities is going to result in making. The
cost of ownership and maintenance of the shared resources,
much cheaper. The fundamental intusion that makes
sharing hardware resources across the diverse set of users
is the fact that resource usage is typically very burst. If we were to draw.
Let's take one particular resource usage, for instance, memory. If we were to
draw Bala's memory usage over time, it might look like this.
And maybe Piero's need for memory over time may look like this. And Kim's
like this, and so on. Now, adding all of these Dynamic needs of
different user communities, we may see a
cumulative usage pattern that might look like
this. Now, let's consider Bala's cost. If he were to buy his own server,
then he would have to buy. As much as this, because that is the
peak usage that he has and probably he'll want to do more than that just to be
on the safe side. The virtual machine actually has a total available
memory that's much more than the individual needs of any one of these
guys and each of these guys. Get to share the cost
of the total resources among themselves. On a
big enough scale, what this would mean is
that each of these guys will have potentially
access to a lot more resources. Then they can
individually afford to pay for at a fraction
of the cost, because both the cost of
acquiring the resource as well as maintaining it
and upgrading it and so on is borne collectively.
And that in a nutshell is the whole behind utility
computing. That is promoted by data centers world wide and this is how
Amazon, Webservice, Microsoft, and so on they
all provide resource on a shared basis to a wide
clientele. Some of you may have already seen the
connection to what we have seen in the previous lecture. Yes.
Virtualization is the logical extension to the idea of
extensibility or specialization of services that we've seen in the
previous lesson, through the spin and exokernel papers. Only
now, it is applied at a much larger granularity.
Namely an entire operating system. In other
words virtualization is extensibility applied at the
granularity of an entire operating system as
opposed to individual services within an operating system.